so let's keep thinking about different
ways to sit multiple people in a certain
number of chairs so let's say we have
six people we have person a we have
person b
we have person c
person d
person e
and we have person f so we have six
people
and for the sake of this video we're
going to say we want to figure out all
the scenarios all the possibilities all
the permutations all the ways that we
could put them into three chairs so
that's chair number one
chair number two and chair number 3.
this is all review this is covered in
the permutations video but it'll be very
instructive as we move into a new
concept so what are all of the
permutations of putting six different
people into three chairs
well like we've seen before we could
start with the first chair and we say
look if no one says if if we haven't if
we haven't seeded anyone yet
how many different people could we put
in chair number one well there's six
different people who could be in chair
number one let me do that a different
color
there are six people who could be in
chair number one six different scenarios
for who sits in chair number one
now for each of those six scenarios how
many people how many different people
could sit in chair number two
well each of those six scenarios we've
taken one of the six people to sit in
chair number one so that means you have
five out of the six people left to sit
in chair number two or another way to
think about it is there's six scenarios
of someone in chair number one and for
each of those six you have five
scenarios for who's in chair number two
so you have a total of 30 scenarios
where you have seated where you have
seated six people in the first two
chairs
and now if you want to say well what
about for the three chairs well for each
of these 30 scenarios how many different
people could you put in in chair number
three
well you're still going to have four
people standing up not in chairs so for
each of these 30 scenarios you have four
people who you could put in chair number
three so your total number of scenarios
or your total number of permutations
where we care who's sitting in which
chair is 6 times 5 times 4 which is
equal to 120
permutations
per
mutations
now let me just permutations now it's
worth thinking about what permutations
are counting now remember we care when
we're talking about permutations we care
about who's sitting in which chair so
for example
for example
this is one permutation
and this would be counted as another
permutation
and this would be counted as one as
another permutation this would be
counted as another permutation so notice
these are all with the same three people
but we're putting them in different
chairs and this counted that that's
counting this 120. i could keep going we
could have that
or we could have that so we're thinking
in the permutation world we would count
all of these or we would count this as
six different permutations these are
going towards this 120 and of course we
have other permutations where we involve
other people where we have it could be f
b c
f
c b
f a c
f
f actually let me do this way i would be
a little bit more systematic
f
uh let me do it
b
b
f c
b c
f and obviously i could keep going i do
120 of these i'll do i'll do two more
you could have c
f
b
and then you could have c
b f so the permutation world these are
these are literally 12 of the 120
permutations but what if we all what if
all we cared about is the three people
were choosing to sit down but we don't
care in what order that they're sitting
or which chair they're sitting so in
that world
these would all be one
this is all this is all the same set of
three people if we don't care which
chair they're sitting in
this would also be the same set of three
people
and so this question if i have six
people sitting in three chairs how many
ways can i choose three people out of
the six where i don't care which chair
they sit on and i encourage you to pause
the video and try to think of what that
number would actually be
well a big clue was when we we
essentially wrote all of the
permutations where we've picked a group
of three people we see that there's six
ways of arranging the three people when
you pick a certain group of three people
that turned into six permutations and so
if you all you want to do is care about
well how many different ways are there
to choose three from the from the six
you would take your whole permutations
you would take your number of
permutations
you would take your number of
permutations and then you would divide
it by the number of ways to arrange
three people number
of ways
to arrange
arrange
three people
and we see that you can arrange three
people or even three letters you can
arrange it in six different ways so this
would be equal to 120
divided by six
or this would be equal to 20.
so there were 120 permutations here if
you said how many different arrangements
are there of taking six people and
putting them into three chairs that's
120. but now we're asking another thing
we're saying if we start with 120 people
and we want to choose and we want to
sorry if we're starting if we're
starting with six people and we want to
figure out how many ways how many
combinations how many ways are there for
us to choose
three of them
then we end up with 20 combinations
combinations
of people this right over here once
again this right over here is just one
combination is the combination a
b c i don't care what order they sit in
i i've chosen them i've chosen these
three of the six this is a combination
of people i don't care about the order
this right over here is another
combination it is f
c and b once again i don't care about
the order i just care that i've chosen
these three people so how many ways are
there to choose three people out of six
it is 20. it's the total number of
permutations it's 120 divided by the
number of ways you can arrange three
people